une production du studio sf météo sans
fil
le podcast on parle de ce qu'on veut
nous inviter des six cantons avec moi
d'une plante
cette semaine le sans fil très présente
et encore une fois par terre et un
terrien terriens terriens c'est un
bureau de comptable ça fait plus de 25
ans qui oeuvrent dans le domaine
ils sont spécialisés dans les pme de 1 à
100 employés dans les domaines d'avenir
c'est à dire informatique jeux vidéo
biotechnologies et studios de podcasts
parce qu'elle a gagné on a développé une
relation de proximité avec les gars de
chez terrain terriens sont nos comptes a
maintenant pour la business puis c'est
aussi des deux outils aux fidèles
auditeurs d'une caste exactement il
offre un service clé en main on préfère
la tenue de livres les états financiers
les rapports d'impôt demande des crédits
d'impôts tout ça est encore plus puis
contrairement aux grandes firmes qui en
fait qui suce vous utilisent ou
voudraient comme un simple numéro
terriens terriens eux il ya vraiment un
rapport humain avec votre comptable vous
allez pouvoir comprendre qu'est ce qui
se passe et pas seulement être traité
comme une demande parmi tant d'autres si
vous utilisez le code sans filtre lors
de votre prise deux premiers rendez-vous
vous allez sauver 50 % sur votre
première année financière c'est à dire
prendre cet argent leur planète dans
votre business à place la mettre en
comptabilité puis ça vous allégez d'un
fardeau financier que je n'avais pas
besoin quand vous commencez votre
compagnie ou cas vous voulez grossir
votre compagnie donc allez sur triple w
point terriens trait d'union super au
point com pour plus d'informations et
pour prendre votre premier rendez vous
en utilisant le code sans filtre c'est
le halal et livre ses besoins elle est
libre pauvre est pour vrai pour réels
progrès à aller les voir aller les voir
alors nettement à l'est cette semaine on
reçoit yannick de martino un humoriste
préférée de nos humoristes préférés de
nos personnes un gosse
que j'aimerais qu'ils sont mon ami mais
cliquer je peux l'appeler mon ami mais
j'aime beaucoup
yannick cette deuxième fois sous le
poids de 4 points en 4 et hispanophone
c'était encore aussi le fun italie deep
d'ailleurs que dans le premier ces temps
ci ont au fil du temps j'ai l'impression
le clown tally puisque le gie relation
avec sa mère de l'équipe mais tous ceux
parfois c'était ben sérieux et parfois
vous connaissez c'est un coq et drôle on
ne rit comme comme jamais ben je rajoute
à dire c'est pas le fun enjoy ouais
c'est yann et qui fait effectué riz de
trucs qui sont pas trop juste par la
façon qu'ils en parlent c'est un gars
brillant mène vraiment me briefe 5e qui
réfléchit beaucoup ça paraît sur sur les
relations sur la vie sur plein de sujets
fait qu'il vieillit très sage est loin
si vous écoutez présentement sur balado
prière de laisser un gain de 5 étoiles
ça fait vraiment son bout de chemin et
un commentaire aussi c'est super
important pour pour l'algorithme si vous
suivez sur youtube que participants
comment à la conversation en fait on
aime ce vous lire
l'on a de moins en moins de temps de
répondre à tout le monde mais sachez qu
on vous lit quand on lit les
commentaires ce matin par le fun chèques
sur le dernier podcast j'espère passer
la soirée hier à lire tous les
commentaires seront pas de casse puis on
aime ça voulait dire c'est le fun que
vous participiez on se crée une
communauté comme ça tranquillement si
vous aimez les sans filtre ce qu'on fait
vous pouvez vous abonner à notre
batterie en aide et sans filtre ou vip
où est-ce qu'on soit des gens moins
connus
puis en plus pétrole s'est
définitivement la meilleure façon de
nous encourager
donc allez voir seul le lien voie
d'adoption du podcast
sinon honnêtement j'espère vous allez
bien bonne écoute ça va
[Musique]
colossal et yannick salut tu viens
d'assister à la dernière journée notre
ordinateur au studio je pense que le ce
a fait un bond est arrivé est arrivé à
la 51e minute koné s'est déréglé enfin
pouvoir commencer
j'ai essayé de faire ma part ouais ok
mais je pense que c'était le dernier
merci tabassian semaine avec tout ça
fait cinq ans qu'on parle qu'on disait
en faire vraiment intéressante il répète
dans le podcast maintenant c'est très
beau fakir fait comment parler de temps
dans la dernière fois tu étais venu
tutelle talons c'est ton show qui
commençait plate a commencé à le tourner
un peu comment l expérience c'est cool
c'est ben je m'amuse c'est en train de
se construire je pense que je suis prêt
du duduk alerte que je veux qu'il le
contenu ce soit je m'amuse dedans a
modifié certains blocs et tout mais ça
se passe bien que je comptais titan
quand l'état est ce que tu arrives en
cas d'une nouvelle affaire complètement
et ont acquis un nouveau numéro sur tel
sujet à soi je laissais web et comme je
disais mon numéro d'introduction là ça
fait deux shows qui existe trois fois
par les milieux c'est quelque chose
qu'on semble commencer par le début je
veux penser dans les milieux demandeur
quatre ans par le début quand commence
pas ton salut après cinq ans à la fin
bref très grands pesant
merci d'arrêter leur mercie charest mais
ouais c'est ça mon numéro un est trop ça
fait ça fait deux fois le break d'une
veste et mais surtout au niveau
conceptuel parce qu'elle jouait dans des
petites salles au début début puis on
dirait que le cette proximité leur faire
en sorte que c'est plus difficile
testé des concerts ouais on dirait que
un concept c'est là tout le temps broche
à foin carte est trop proche c'est
peut-être façade un concept pire
gagne que ça à temps par concept à fond
l'idée de la balle avec laquelle tu
joues tu pareil c'est le format a fait
format stand-up andres parfait caractère
4 tonnes bonne proximité avec les gens
ça parle tout le temps mieux parce que
tu sais c'est plus intime tu parles pour
de vrai tu t'adresses aux gens en un
concept comme instance de plus de voici
un peu moins un personnage où il ya
comme un quatrième mort qui se forment
donc c'est plus difficile qu'un quand
les gens sont je sais pas moi sont 150
qui sont vraiment prêtes toi il ya de
quoi qui fait un peu assez qu'on a envie
de voir
mais dans une salle un petit peu plus
grand bain le ça devient intéressant
parce que ça fait plus partie d'un
spectacle à en faire appliquer donc
cette idée le chômage avait déjà testé
l'idée justement dans des plus petits
endroits et c'était catastrophique
je parle là ça fonctionne déjà les
retravailler aussi je pense que c'est
meilleur que le premier jet mais la
question initiale c'était ce qui est en
forme et ont jugé qu'un vidéo toyas
piste et le poème sur la go bh c'est
vrai c'est un concept enfants parce
qu'un concept suscite des besoins des
spas technique il ya quoi de plus que
juste l'humoriste qui parle encore d'un
exact parce que j'imagine que je
m'envole soudan dans un bar où ce que
c'est vraiment très très très peu de
base avec et je pense pas que ça leur
ait le même effet que dans un gala juste
pour rire ce qui fait un niveau plus que
dans un ballon était d'écouter il va se
fait à paris - l'avocat neda si tu
regardes tu te concentres sur l'or en
tant que tel quand d'autres stimuli tu
peux regarder la fin de la game de
hockey en europe league et se met à
parler de son propre aveu ça se soit
porté à regarder autre chose se soit
exact en direct
moi c'est ça il ya un niveau qui est
plus dur à lire ouais c'est cette up
brûlante et de bord où son site off
c'est chabrol ouais mais bon je veux
dire de marne le mettant en fait ce
choix comme dans ses besoins de face et
j'aimerais aller me paraît donc
j'aimerais rectifié moi je trouve pas
que c'est de la merde j'ai vraiment du
plaisir et pour devrait aller d'un papy
ça me permet vraiment de tester c'est
juste vraiment y aller plus avec du cnda
mais je dirais pas par exemple que même
au contraire moi j'aime ça j'aime
vraiment ça allait proposer justement
mon type d'idées dans des endroits
peut-être ça se passe quand tu vois
touati sont pas au courant de ce qui
s'en vient puis sûrement plus réceptifs
dans un bon soir je pense que maintenant
les gens ils savent pas à quoi
s'attendre je capable
c'est vraiment plus qu'est-ce que je
parle est elle rabaisse les numéros
conceptuel que j'irais pas faire dans un
bar parce que c'est même pas par rapport
des fois les coûte déjà c'est juste par
rapport à ce que je peux faire ça va en
voir la broche à foin comme que je dis
maintenant je le prends comme ça à
goberge mais il faut j'emmène je sais
pas maté vrillaud mon ipad pour montrer
mon affaire en même temps salah et de
n'importe quoi même afin que mon numéro
d'un truc pour expliquer votre vitre
s'est coincé que j'ai eu une radio puis
un mois côté la radio c'est ma voix
donc il ya comme trop d'éléments que si
c'est pas beau visuellement déjà le
salaire des n'importe quoi à place que
de 20 comme et écoute pete & young
une belle mise en scène assez
intéressant c'est plus pour ce parce que
sinon j'aime ce faire les bars mais par
contre je ne fais pas ce moment beaucoup
puis en tournée du type épaule ses
effectifs et les salles de spectacle et
tous ces jeux sans une entente avec les
femmes parce que moi sinon je
continuerai le j'aime vraiment ce que je
voulais dire j'étais jeune ça m'a dit
que tous les bars sont bruns et sa maman
mais vraiment rectifie le tir parce que
jamais tous les bords sont bruns mais
arrive pas encore à 17 heures des fois
de chaud que tu dis x iboy serment pop
ti malice in mais dont les conditions où
les leçons l'éclairage ou l inverse
sinon c'est clair mais chiant le dérange
pas je suis chanceux de 300 d'halloween
et ouais je voudrais que que je dise des
jobs dans un endroit que c'est un peu
moyen comme esthétiquement et lâche
comme général
je gagne ma vie je veux pas être le cas
face à princess commença xiaoli de faire
comme mon nom n'est trop beau
des fois c'est plus en fait ça va être
plus 2 par rapport à comment des gens
sont briffeuil sur le chocolat par
exemple car il faut retrouver un peu
plat ce matin je sais pas moi je m'en
veux enfin justement un corpo je peux
moi saint-hyacinthe plus personne et au
courage tout le monde et dont le ca est
de martin hoff de personnes écoutent ça
en train de manger un dessert
ben je sais pas si je serai plus
l'ambiance que mon frère valeurs est-ce
qu'on peut le jouer un petit peu me
respecte
on a parlé avec ça me retombe chemin
dernièrement comme savoir qu'est-ce qui
est qu'est-ce qui est met dans des
situations optimale ou des situations
mardan et corpo justement le camelot lui
disaient leur lors laquelle tu joues une
sur un netbook trop tard non non je
t'envie de décor au delà du booking des
fouilles comme il le faut faire tirer
les cadeaux j'ai été content parce que
sacacomie
c'est aussi c'est un hôtel près de trois
rivières mais comme leur art et des
finissants de l'université de
trois-rivières l'on m'avait bouquet pour
que j'arriverai au nord je suis ok mais
ça ça me rend un peu nerveux parce que
le décor pose surtout que je pense comme
si c'est beaucoup moins d'expérience ça
fait pas longtemps que finalement ça
dérange pas un groupe que dans le fond
on a moins 15 minutes de retard mais
fait 45 à place du nord que je fais ok
mais vous me payer le même prix ou we
will be allowed
et finalement ça a été plus long que
prévu le monde ont peaufiné leur propre
espace adhérent je suis comme cela ne
s'est pas arrêtée jusqu'à temps qu'ils
me disent ça dérange plus on va être
donneur bracelet puis juste c'est bien
payé avec nous prendre un fait un peu
cher payé
oui oui même ma femme était restée atone
et chez castel à dijon
j'avais un char du pilote qui arrive à
tout le monde d'accord ce que tu fais le
toi c'est toi le fait qu'il fait ce que
sera notre parti mais j'avais déjà
ramené moi d'arrêter gag
j'avais emmené mes dessins je vais je
fais des dessins aussi il y avait une
fuite rosso qui avait vomi semé d andré
des logis expliqué le géant comme
lorsque jean guilaine fait trop soldat
qui avait vomi pendant l'été quatre pays
en jeu contre le poteau le ch comme
avatar est plus juste pour me raconter
associe d'un dessin je t'aimerai mais
choqué j'étais comme cela et prix du
texte est passé de réussir trois ce
dessin et le jeu tellement fort chez
l'insecte cet accueil festif avons mis
plus haut niveau me fait pas réfléchir
ou est ce qui m'est arrivé aussi le
matin c'est la faulx que je tombais ou
six étaient le plus humide ya cette même
soirée le maquis ouais bah oui est ce
que vous voulez y avait comme des hommes
comme dans un club l'autre idée du genre
de deux tubes de danser dessus pendant 7
6 1 il y avait une fille qui danse des
mois gt gt gt
c'est dit je t'appelle pillay avait
comme de c'était glissant par terre
en tout cas avec finalement jugé t elle
ma tombe et j'accroche estime jean 14
balles puis - par réflexe j'ai voulu
m'accrocher après deux coups et la
prochaine je n'étais t elle ma force je
compte me change mais ce que je mets
cela j'ai pas déchirés ou l'ag patrick
complètement g-strings sur les j'étais
vraiment gêné n'existait pas volontaire
de d'après seulement m'ont dit hitchcock
et puis moi je pense qu il me parla
amour peau est elle oui mais c'est
humiliant ne m'en fais pas trop qu'on
parle je n'ai quand même si c'est la
même soirée qu'on parle je me sens
vraiment mal pour elle mais j'ai la
similienne gratuit toi ian et martin aux
côtés d'aso c'est là c'était à cette
équipe maintenant à 6 go le il m'a
arraché l'ag penneçot horrible dans
toute sa vie ça va être cet humoriste le
mais je pense à lebiez vue il y avait
vraiment pauvre longtemps c'était de la
survie
saleh comme un échec tombe c'est ça
exact plus tard métaphore rester par
faire parler elle est géniale
c'est ce serait en fait je suis
littéralement un show j'ai tombé non
mais ouais c'est ça non mais moi je bois
je sors mes griffes qui est le maillot
mais je me sens mal pour garde parce que
de son côté elle alors soccer et c'est
non sans compter c'est juste un coup
corte ces juges chargés d'histoire qui
est payé pour être dans mes vêtements
cette faute est tombé non je tombe sur
scène mais ton way we were au mikes
parce que j'ai d'ailleurs parti de jean
thomas jobin
puis c'est évidemment un début
connaissait ne connaissent pas qu'il
vienne voir en plus une première partie
des foules d'amendé jamais rien fait
elle a encore dit me connaissaient pas
au fait que je vous ai dit qu'il y avait
comme une préparation un peu négative et
je rentre sur scène je m'en charge dans
mes équipes je tombe en pleine face à
une première chose fils ma première
chance avec déjà son homme mon dieu
c'est qui le tarif qui ça vient sourcing
le match complet demain chez ea qui
s'est apprécié t on dirait que le match
de caen avec la confiance d'isaac pas un
stand up c'est important on dirait
d'avoir la confiance peut être un peu
colleter de j j'ai dit je pars avec -18
et je te l'avais vu j'en ai pleuré je
pense que mais les syndicats j'avais un
peu comme la l'avouer l'abritera mois
mais savoir bien oui toi tu es wasquehal
moyens ça va bien vous parce que les
oies blanches barbie souvent je me suis
aussi une fois je tente quand tu tombes
devant les chars le temps est gris rouge
c'est tout et c'est à lui mirent à ses
pieds tant pis mais moi je marche pas
dans mes pieds
ça tombe bien juste mokhtar garde web et
7 c sur chateaubriand à la hauteur de
jean talon a fait un rappel quelques
places et non mais pourquoi je me sens
fort j'ai nommé piétons bas pleine face
le chu janet et je me touche le nez
chaîne charmont tube ses gènes
c'est un navet ou comme ça ol au bord de
la rue barbusse jetant à l'eau à
l'épicerie parce que j'adore
chateaubriand brille un coin jean talon
le métro les sandwichs autant avec du
pain aux olives ciabatta zholy ktz ont
fait là bas
vraiment ils sont délicieux je mangeais
tout ans et j'étais tellement emballé
jeté comme un jour d'aller chercher mon
sandwich aujourd'hui autant chaîne mais
ça a été réconforté dans sa nouvelle gt2
rs faire des pubs pour métro on a un
code pour le mondial mais je vous jure
il sent vraiment à ben sulayem à face et
je sais pas c'est quoi leur secret mais
délicieux le ccri ouais les vosges et
rien ça m'apprend à djerba mariale le
métro ah ouais celui là non non je
travaillais juste une petite heure fois
plus loin sur de normanville qui est un
petit épicerie nous excuser c'est
comique parce que moi j'ai été cachés
arrivée à montréal
j'ai été porté aux seules séries il
monsieur s'appelait robert j étais un
monsieur qui ont un grand coeur mais il
sait que sexy dans la façon qui parle
c'est quelqu'un que tu dis je t'aime
petit répond ok c'est un ouais c'est ça
c'est vraiment ce genre de monsieur diop
j'ai été porté mon cerveau ya regarde
que tu loeb après midi ok parfait que le
jeu rend dans l'après-midi le jeu fait
c'est quoi mon rôle
in spite le gérait des fruits et légumes
je suis déjà gérer
j'irai pas d'expérience mais y était et
est réellement sous x avait pas de sens
quand j'ai commencé il ya déjà des
employés non qu'ils avaient trop
d'employés c'est un tout petit épicerie
de lioujas trois rangées c'est lui qui
son frère et son frère qui ont comme
cette épicerie là il n'y avait pas
d'employer des fruits et légumes lui
était juste à nous de prendre sa
retraite
puis qui était moi j'ai fait rentrer mon
coloc dans l'épicerie que lui
travaillait pour son frère et c'était le
jour et la nuit lui l'aspect zcp moi mon
boss cobayes bâton évidemment je me suis
amené les clémentines et en arabe et ses
moules gérait des fruits et légumes du
maudit et annick t'as pas comment a dit
clémentine s'est jamais oublier de
commander dans l'épicerie des
clémentines
mais il est tard spécial facture monte
quand même là dans la circulaire il ya
des chemises rouges
c'est mon erreur je suis maître g t au
mon erreur on n'a pas commandé il ya un
impôt très mal commencé vous en avez pas
piste à ce paysage
je vous lis saison derrière l'amour
aller dans un autre mais trop madame qui
fit lui chaut capot je me souviens cette
journée là n'étaient pas fâchés contre
moi il dit trouver ça drôle une des
tours et le thé perdu
ok 1 de bouche et de 0,6 dans les airs
et jeta joris certains il ya dix ans on
perd trop ce qu'ils disaient royal
jallieu chaque pays a échappé mais dans
un rôle de passeur il faut qu'on
mangeait de la tarte au sucre
dès mon ami lui mon coloc en affaires il
se faisait passer des commandes châble
let's go il faut travailler fort par
l'exode ont mangé plata et on a revenant
à la porte le soir j'étais quand même
c'est ridicule c'est santé et rossi qui
fait le mot au sérieux lester ridicule
comment à lui n'est spécifique aussi les
mots ce test est des fois il m'appelait
hills high tech ratera matin je vais non
le futur andré cet après midi je droit
métier comme tight 1h30 pas de trop puis
me faisais du stade et des fois que je
rentrais pour devrait être deux heures
puis me fait des chèques comme j'avais
travaillé plus mauvais que je dirige et
d'échoppés
je vois pas de trop puis commence et qui
tripatouillent je sais pas je pense
qu'il me trouvait gentil on a eu ces
mots il était juste vraiment à se battre
avec moi pour rire était têtu un bon
employé août était le père employé alors
je t'aime mauvais non mais bon quel
poète et perdit nathan mais ce
changement
j'avais pas d'un intérêt à travailler
lors en plus d'être perdu c'est comme un
mix à s'exploser aucune motivation
oublie tout ce qu'ils disent qu'ils
doivent faire il s'en fout et pas bondi
il veut pas s'améliorer employés bien
manger est à tous et que nous sommes
élus que je dis lui ces gens sont ici
qui appartenait je pense à sa mère à la
base ils ont comme irrité fait que lui
et il ya des blocs appartements et tout
donc tout ça la lettre tout seul comme
il y avait une soixantaine d'années où
il était brave à l'acte ah oui c'était
malade il parlait chaque jour qui sont
riley on parlait le cje ce qu'on faisait
on parlait pour se perdre et il ya plus
de 40 ans à rouiller plusieurs pas de
légumes qui en fait moi aussi bon sens
le club pour qu'on soit jazz et puis
nous est une terre moins de yannick mora
ivre cette faille de la moto marche at
elle dit
deuxième des greens nord c'était
vraiment un simple de chair oui mais je
travaille rabat est pas une femme moi
j'ai jamais parlé des deux couches et a6
ou rien c'est juste forêt de la moto le
titre seulement là il se voyait elle a
lui promis qu'ils désavouent secteur et
en colombie britannique d'al arish à
leurs cadres au en colombie-britannique
en moto qui marche en tête avec aucun
aucun aucune connotation sexuelle dans
son rail très bref
carmat qui pensent qu'il peut atteindre
s'est senti tout le temps pour chasser
nos rails
mais je pense qu'il voulait que ça reste
dans le domaine du fanta parce que
j'amène parlait de séduction ou deux
parce que oui tu fais comme mme comets
boeing madame chantal il faut convaincre
et établissant un lien avant de faire de
la moto avec en colombie britannique
puis il n'y avait pas de plaie même que
cache posait la question on dirait que
j'allais en cause trop loin ce qui était
comme tout ça et voulait plus parler des
trains dans le domaine du réel des
comores c'est quand même une bonne
première job pour ton arrivée à montréal
ces décalages 19-12 dont une grille mais
le moi j'avais un ami qui travaille au
jardin mobile fille lui il voulait
mettre son savoir ce qu'est le travail
et le pays comptait les bananes puis
date de l'emmener ya eu une promotion
pour d'énergie et fait deux jours en
otage et renvoie ce que les comptes et
puis les bananes qui avait plus de
responsabilités et aller voir son boss
et faites le moi je veux juste compter
les bananes sais tu fais qu'un mais
redescend mois puis mais un objet rare
parce que moi c'est pas ça je veux
finalement compter les bananes encore je
suis pour mettre son savoir-faire diable
à vous je comprends seul regret même nom
il mettra au jour des mobilités dans
tout l'est que tes aspirations sont mais
son pôle sa dépouille en eux que oui
parce qu'il y en ait que j'ai vu me dit
dans le fossé scellé seul job j'ai fait
le rapport de l'humour les prêts dans
des épiceries puis à g et justement je
faisais ça et je me souviens de prirent
patron j'ai une mervyn et s'appelait
jacques lé souhait que le gars était ama
qui lui son petit président vistelle
sommes engueulés du monde
au secondaire pense que lyon au mal
placé de cannage mais je pense à
premières infos vraies images me
je me suis pas nier que quelqu'un
s'était lui séduit je devrais même
emmené parce que parce qu'en fait manger
y avait comme un jeu mais si c'était
entre comme ayant violé quelqu'un pile
de jetons comme c'est la personne seule
à la personne était vraiment humiliée
pas capable se défendre j'ai compris sa
défense
je pourrais tu es gentil rêver quoi
demain est fait vraiment acheté avec ça
faisait capoter que je te comme man
c'est le sait à quel point d'inviter
pour réussi pour que s'appliquent à
d'engueuler des jeunes les adultes
j'avais crashé son bureau j'avais caché
son bureau il m'avait mis devant vrai
c'est pas si grand que seul nom mais
piste avec ses toiles comme ils
travaillent ici alors je défaite devant
acquitter leur nom je les fait devant
lui il m'a engueulé puis il me dit que
je n'ai pas un bon employé mais j'étais
comme ici à quel point la torche merde
de mal placé des cannes de ton genre qui
peut déjà qu'ils agissent ont dit à ce
sommet mais en plus j'ai rien contre les
gens qui font ce gie pour deux
réalisations des bureaux non mais pour
de vrais c pa par rapport à sa fonction
par rapport à son travail c'est vraiment
par rapport à son nom est cité comme en
plus c'est tout le temps si tu m'entends
le le vrai patron le propriétaire tout y
passait sur exemple mais la personne qui
se fait donner un petit peu de pouvoir
mais pas trop si lui qui paye la carte
au fait que ces gens là j'ai retourné il
ya pas longtemps cette épicerie de
jallet crawl en moulin
non parce que jal fois lorsque rendu le
jeu tamati je sais qui tu es jolie vu
dans son regard qui m'ont reconnu pitt
ou non je veux ça va pas et mes enfants
pour rajouter de l'arrogance je parle
que peu de sel dans la dentelle
moi c'est ce jeu parce que jk j'avais 15
ans ma réaction le fait défendre leur
personne ce que j'ai dit avec des jeux
comme atteint la cible donc l'homme m
c'est quelqu'un qui prend pas très bien
avec elle même si elle date
je pense que non la première devrait du
rapport coaché en natation c'est dans
une cage aux sports je te plongeurs je
devais avoir 16 ans jean puis je suis
rentré lapidiales un gars qui étaient là
qui était la plonge c'est comme son
domaine il fallait pas que je le fais
chier dans planches puis mon année j'ai
eu comme une jarre de promotion est ce
que j'allais faire cuire les ailes de
poulet en arrière dans une fille pendant
que j'étais comme dans la ligne pour
faire cuire les aides
le gars qui comme l'est la plonge lui a
donné de la marque le temps que gta
plonge juste encore a plongé les médias
ap hm et des plus jeunes la marque que
j'allais l'aider à faire la plonge
inclus tu es dans un rush tout le moins
avec le tout le bon coureur que j'avais
selon jalel aider même si ça me mettait
dans marde d'amener le seul qui était le
boss des cuisines le gérant des cuisines
qui était comme maintenant les rangs du
haut placé dans la cage aux sports
années et a ruiné cuisine puis de me
voir
rappelons qu'un comme c'était le rush
partout ailleurs puisque là ils savaient
pourquoi j'étais là parce que l'orgueil
arrêtez pas mener de la marque pour être
le ya juste comme complètement flippé
puis quand c'est à reims et l'autre
groupe m
être français après mois des claude
charland classe s'y plongent leur tourne
le monde je retourne en arrière plus
mais à reims et le double de la moyenne
et les premières jobs 97 c'est un
magasin music si je vendais des dictats
des enfants si il y avait deux bosses un
foule ce matin puis un tortionnaire
ultime un dictateur c'est un jeep jaune
quand j'arrivais dans le parking puis je
voyais qu'il était le joaillier sont jim
jones j'avais envie de faux parce que je
le savais que si mettons c'était
tranquille
il a promis qu'il fera plaisir van mois
sa place à lui que georges patient ce
pitch de vente par fait des petits gars
de 17 ans qui connaît pas tellement son
enfant qui est pas nécessairement là
pour une guerre pilotes
vingt mois la gibson à 2500 élèves une
batterie sacoche mais tellement beau
humain que tout s'est affolé quand les
salariés a apprécié mauges et aux filles
be - gens j'ai fait accompli capable je
peux faire sur l'excellent magasin a
fermé ses magasins la fff ait pu ne pas
rester mais makhzen musique qui
fonctionne et que tu as une relation
d'aidé et de confiance avec ton vendeur
donne à voir pillé sma qui est drôle
c'est mais le talent et le petit est
quelqu'un de différent parce qu'il ya
des précédents ployer tf1 que j'ai
jamais compris non plus pourquoi les
patrons fonctionne pas plus avec le
renforcement positif à place du stress
et toutes les autres
qu'est ce qui fonctionne pour de vrai ça
c'est la technique du renforcement
positif j'ai fait un bon coup tu vas
avoir envie de faire un autre bon court
moment qu'on veut le souvenir des camps
mais félicitations en place de justesse
un fausse passe plus de temps surtout
que souvent et pas assez
c'est simple et surtout des jobs qui
était un des occupants d'emploi vraiment
c'est leur business et il veut que ça
fonctionne c'est clair passer sur leur
vie mais qui fait mal et engage un jeune
je sais pas si cette première expérience
de travail dans la vie cette façon
qu'ils soient positives ou je veux
siégea première premier job c'est
classique logement des déblais
d'einstein qui s'est classé lens pour
aider les dindes au colloque de maïs
vendait des bleus dans la maman des
stations service c'est exact j'étais
tellement gêné je me suis fait mettre
dehors de ce côté m'as tu contenant les
bleus ça ne s'est pas trop la bonne
douzaine d'années de 14
quelque chose comme sur le gnl et je me
suis je voulais plus je voulais plus
impressionnant on va engager dans une
station service et j'ai fait juste la
formation comme étant les trois heures
qu'on montre comment les ponts étaient
comme que le dimanche peut être quand
même anxieux dans la vie des fois
l'anxiété faire en sorte qu'il n'y a
plus rien qui rentrent en jeu ça comment
les jeunes
ouais t'as pas d'abord la stupide c'est
exactement le style plus stupide il n'y
avait pas d'information qui rendrait je
me suis que la personne ont jamais mangé
jamais rappelé que j'applique un gpu
encore mon horaire non c'est bon on va
te donner bientôt et jamais ils tanguent
ose t aimons go moi ce que j'ai fait
peut-être parce que justement je
fournissais paulo je comprenais pas ça
rentrait pas trop stressé ouais on veut
te l'envoyer modem
pis leur appui sur un point
d'interrogation
c'est en ces temps ci c'est dans le sac
à main qu'il ya du monde qui sont faites
pour faire une télé pour faire quelque
chose puis excellent et là dedans mais
qu' on a parlé d'éthique en or
suffisante nadeau le lay ou buzz le ca
nous dit qu'il a tout c'est justement
c'est le job était pourri et aime trop
mais les hypermarchés pau puis faire des
vidéos sur youtube elle ça marchait
dessus et puis ça faisait pas ce qu'est
ce qui la ferait une bonne question de
méthode possession des fois ci faisait
pas du mot qu'est ce que je ferai ouais
je pense en fait j'aurais travaillé en
création là c'est moi je regardais
beaucoup pour la pub
je pense j'aurais pu travailler là
dedans sinon j'aime écrire en général
moins de meyrals c'est d'écrire un
dessin animé reid
c'était vraiment ça donc écrit pour
d'autres maurice soucy ça aurait pu me
placer un scripteur où je sais pas je
pense jamais au delà par exemple en
dehors de la création jeu je ne sais pas
notre j'aurais peut-être mais ce être
psychologue
ouais moi j'aime vraiment mais je ne
sais pas si j'avais eu les qualificatifs
look'n'be mais j'aurais aimé étudié en
psychologie toujours aimé ce dessus
c'est une question personnelle mais je
suis consultant parce que j'y suis tout
à fait le genre à qui s'adresse cette
chose là bas c'est pas ça qui a fait en
sorte que
que j'aime ça parce qu'on passait le
contrat vu que je m'intéresse à ce si
j'avais pas de réticence à aller
consulter
puis je me suis jamais dit je comprends
pas que ça existe encore cette mentalité
le de six pôles psychologue détail
malades
maintenant tout est conçu parce que la
personne c'est juste pour faire du
cheminement avant d être mieux outillés
pour mieux outils pour se développer
donc moi je n'ai senti aucune réticence
puis ça tu étais que positif tant que
ces poteaux en acier t ous les pots à la
base barbaste pour quelque chose de plus
spécifique
en fait pour ma relation avec ma main
qu'on a un peu comme on se parlait pas
vraiment où puis je voulais juste
établir un lien pouvoir pouvoir ils
doivent être que j'avais envie et je
pense que j'avais on a besoin comme de
d'une autre personne qui furent un peu
de temps ensemble
le médiateur c'est exact phi phi phi
ce soir il ya apprécié j'ai construite
voir cette psychologue le seul parce que
des trucs que c'est encore plus facile
pour moi qui ai vu qu'elle avait vu ces
choses là c'est dur à expliquer qu'elle
ait vu ma relation maman il ya des trucs
c'est long explique et payman même
comprend aussi la personne part est ce
qu'il ya des éléments qui exagèrent ou
site
est ce que c'est de sa perception a des
fois ça peut pas partir si ta perception
ça peut être bien ridé comme ok mais
ceux ci sont d'interprétation et tout
donc le cas les vu certaines choses ça
m'a aidé à ses yeux donner accès comme
certains éléments qui est dame
comprendre puisque pour ce que j'ai
construit de voir cette psychologue
c'était le des acquis de moi à toi
voyage avait aucun lien que maman je
parlais plus rapide à mango on va
l'appeler comme
me parlait m'a donné que j' ai dit
écoute nous la seule façon que
j'accepterai d'être par alice ce serait
dans ce contexte la highway
c'est quand même j'allais dire mature
mais ce n'est pas le mot mais c'est
quand même et je sais pas je suis pas le
mot que je cherche mais cette ça demande
une certaine acceptation de ta position
faut peut-être soit quand même bien
conscient d'être une sorte de votre
relation au bon goût un certain désir de
réellement régler ce problème
wahou keeway oui je lui avais sur moi
mais aussi le désir de devenir maman
veut pas à vieillir
[ __ ] ça fait peut-être 4 en dessous
elle avait fait une phlébite puis je
voyais comme je sens ma allumés de
commettre sa santé pourrait que ce soit
pour l'internement wassup donc avait des
trucs que je laime
je le verbaliser que j'avais jamais fait
puis là je me dis ok c'est avec le temps
ou jamais ouais enfin je voulais me
libérer de certaines choses
cette sainte libéré ouais ouais ouais
mais aussi de leurs rapports avec elle
ses réactions m'a fait mieux comprendre
la personne qui - ça m'a aidé à la
toiture et concilier avec certaines
souvenir que tu avais les ajustements
certains certains trucs pas sa rentrée
tous les détails sur sa non ça me
dérange pas ça me dérange pas mais c'est
un peu compliqué mais j'ai comme c'est
très particulier que maman le progrès
enfin que je dirais que c'est comme rui
inde les souvenirs mouvement ça c'est
andré toute ma vitesse comme cause même
si elle existait plus je me souvenais
plus de grand chose ça refait surface
comme fin et je vais rejoindre il
fallait qu'on fait moi je n'ai pas connu
mon père avant l'âge de 18 ans ma mère
c'était bon flou qui se faisait dans la
vie tout il ya beaucoup d'éléments
harmonie avec ma famille c'était c'est
très particulier quand même donc on
croise et se jeter curieux qui avait des
souvenirs j'avais même pas s'il était
vrai ou pause c'était moins même avoir
déjà demandé ce que je fabule ou en
respectant pas c'était pour toi
tellement flou que tu étais même pas
persuadé que c'était réel
chris horner et avaient été réels est-ce
que c'est par mécanisme
de ton cerveau est ce que c'est par
protection de ben je pense à 50 50
une partie que c'est vraiment conscient
que je n'ai pu donner d'importance à ce
et 50% que c'est comme inconsciente qui
est pro le mans - le tour de france
parce que je parle je me suis vraiment
concentré moi j'ai voulu un peu me
sortir de mon pasteur une familiale si
je voyais que autour de moi ça s'en
sortait pas aussi très semmam avoir été
subie à nice sociale toute sa vie et
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de ces sur ma
famille sa voix par rapport à mon père
m'a ça y est comme arrivé beaucoup
beaucoup d'événements que moi j'ai voulu
vraiment me sortir vite de tout ça est
brisé la rule mois fait que quelqu'un
commence à faire du monde est touché
j'étais quand même assez carriériste
j'ai eu un enfant 18 ans bref que je
pense que je veux pas je veux pas que
cette enfant soit élevée dans la roue et
je les vois qu'il ya là où il y avait
sur mais il y avait aussi que d'abord eu
un enfant 18 ans gisaient encore lundi
viennent de tomber dans le même pas
trois essais viennent de thé je me
disais je n'ai dit poté qui mon futur je
veux le jeu mais à qui je veux
je pense à travailler en création chez
répond à quoi exactement je faisais
beaucoup d'impro donc je voyais que la
porte était ouverte pas taillé pour lui
m'ont donc je me suis lancé tout de
suite là dedans vu que mon fils n'a
jamais donc je pense au moment que ça a
commencé à fonctionner c'est comme les
premières réussites que j'avais j'avais
que j'avais un retour aussi j'avais je
recevais de l'amour c'était comme
nouveau tout ça pour moi donc je pense
que j'ai car il faut que c'est beaucoup
sur la carre âge de venir à ces
carriéristes donc puis jetée focus sur
ma carrière et mon fils donc j'ai comme
oubliée tout chaud mais un vent menées
çà te rattrape pas ce que veut pas je
suis vraiment heureux par rapport à ma
position résolument dans un humour et
tout mais ça devient même si c'est
vraiment pas une routine ça fait partie
de la routine de bail se fait dans vite
en fait qu'il ya des trucs qui refont
surface au moment que un petit peu plus
en tête de plus l'esprit en paix s aspen
- était pas tout le temps en train de
chercher désespérément rencontre demain
j'espère ce mot si ça va bien aller
des fantômes temps maintenant de
refléter sur le passé ce qui était pas
fait pendant longtemps c'était pas voir
leurs auteurs c'est juste du fait que fx
pour ce mois puis dans le fond c'est des
carrières le devinait de te dit je veux
pas être la personne du bien-être social
toute ma vie mais aussi lundi
deuxièmement j'ai inquiets depuis j'ai
besoin n'est pas vraiment à part au
début parce que moi à la base j'étais
vraiment pas quelqu'un qui avait de la
difficulté à l'école déjà le jeu voyait
que j'en étais pas dans gt pas dans le
même je cadrais patins avec eux c'était
comme nouveau moment
comprenez comme pas leur site web ainsi
se jeta en marge par rapport à 1 heure
par rapport à pipi c'est comme ma soeur
mais elle a eu plus difficile
on peut tomber dans ces moi je suis
vraiment pas tomber alcool drogue touch
to share potiche tu es vraiment comme un
bon petit garçon s'émousse sujet du
couvent à l'improvisation là c'est ce
qui est fait à ce jour tant d'autres
choses c'était tellement ma passion j'ai
eu la chance que c'était extrêmement
populaire mollet à mon école à cambrai
d'ailleurs j'ai c'est drôle parce que
toute mon équipe d'aller promener du
monde maintenant qu'ils sont dans le
milieu nativement mon équipe dans les
provinces étaient éméchés najder qui est
un comédien qui jouait dans embrassement
comme tu m'aimes
il ya jean françois ruel qui est dernier
neuf figures du rap
yes we can you call gagnon qui est
violée de piste au nom de wii justement
c'est lui qui m'a encouragé à faire du
stand up quand j'ai commencé cette
enquête
hakem gagnon qui ont et réalisateur
gabriel a l'air qui est un de mes bons
amis qui est auteur sait on de toutes
sortes un nom dans le milieu que c'est
vrai que j'ai eu la chance de rencontrer
cette gang lui qui comptait vraiment
animé par la création le monde est d
ores et on a gagné le tournoi juste pour
rire
éduc'alcool jazz année qui était comme
le gros tournoi d'un programme trop
selon elle rester tfou lequel on est
devant moi trois on transfère aux
archives a joué trois fois contre la
ligue nationale d'un éperon reste un job
travaux sur éduc'alcool ces genres les
gagnants je pense des tournois existait
c'était juste grainerie arrêta regarde
d'où ce matin les écoles qui ont gagné
c'est granby granby granby granby qui
l'abrité léon de gagner le tournoi
existe et 6 arnaud garnier catherine
conte et chanson expérience c'est fou
on parlait on avait des nôtres ailleurs
un drone à vis de la classe entre les
parties le club qui découvre un pro pis
on n'a pas bien vous à quel point
d'avoir des d'avoir une jarre de
communautés comme l'impro c'est
important c'est moi je voulais justement
je lai comme je dirait l'autre fois
j'allais à lui tout les vendredis la
lumière c'est laval puis tout s'est tu
gagnes le jardin vraiment ça vient des
camarades qui à chaque vendredi au genre
une routine peas et ça c'est des gens
qui qui se trouve une espèce d'entité à
travers l'un propice et tellement je
trouve ça vraiment vraiment que je
trouve que il va en avoir plus mais on
va aborder c'est vraiment des équipes
dans toutes les écoles devraient avoir
des guides ravotti vraiment je trouve ça
m
on a parlé coq depuis j'ai l'impression
que deux coups avec l'impro qui
tellement stimulant à tous les niveaux
du cerveau loti des vestes et d'esprit
ton sens comique pitié souvent ces gens
là les gens qui font des pouilles
donc quelque chose de spécial sont qui
souvent justement dans le monde les
comédiens gan qui viennent seulement
pour le dessus et des musiciens ça
développe quelque chose que oui
j'aimerais beaucoup d'autres choses jay
or sur anthony van damme ricky le silo
de pacifisme c'est un jeune entrepreneur
dans le fond du litige qui est dit qui a
commencé des cours d'un polo sur le c à
montréal puis je vais m'inscrire
alors j'aimerais ça va être vraiment là
on fait tu vaux si c'est vrai mais c'est
comme du niveau le thème et vos oreilles
délicates et qu'un qui pense à ses bons
petits pas au niveau 2 pitt et tu
apprends un peu les codes l'imagination
et au medley aussi que le nonce paul st
c'est quoi le bac
plusieurs étages et en jambes il
ce un jeu de piste a juste cassé sur
saint denis
je me suis dit ok l'otan c'est un
quartier latin ses proches du ces en
face de champion la saison annonce je
vais pas parler compter pour que je les
hais ces races et les sponsors du bac s
mais c'est là c'est ce genre du comfort
food mais entre que c'est juste que
j'avais panier un vin d'os de poulet
dans une pizza végétarienne des gens il
y avait et il y avait du probable est
polygame mais n'y avait pas de viande
clémangis envoyons nos pizzas mais
j'aurais dû y poursuivre ou de coûts
entrepris comme la personne qui la faute
au texte poursuivent chaque fois que tu
as l'occasion
c'est comme la fameuse histoire aux
morts t'imagines se trouve à un rang des
compositions dans talent et post
traumatique
alors que plus jamais mangé
parce que je suis déjà apparemment été
notamment en décomposition avancé et
pouvaient difficilement dire c'était
quoi laisser or sur ces frais tu
continues à ce que je veux dire
les robes rouges passé 105 cette crise
qui est des romans et recueils ont eu
lieu tout comme quatre niveaux le donc
pour ceux qui commencent une bonne ligue
pour jouer devant un petit public comme
quinze vingts personnes je pense dans le
carde habituellement rugueux du juge
j'ai des amis qui ont commencé le sais
je sais pas comment ça franchement cbo
puis tu te prends le tram jusqu'à aussi
si jamais ça se passe bien ouais c'est
une bonne place pour commencer
d'apprendre à penser parce que tit t
la junte vraiment le pire obstacle à
l'improvisation en fait dès que tu
réfléchis et programmes à le laisser
aller c'est là que le naturaliste parce
que dès que tu réfléchis sur comment
mener quand ils développent des parts
pour réfléchir en même temps ça vaut
mais souvent les moments qui vont être
le vraiment vraiment et meilleur match
pour être toujours quand tu penses
absolument rien qui surprend tout moment
c'est là que j'ai découvert un bon
feeling mais c'est faux cul comme
failing des caves où je me suis là des
impôts ce que je suis en particulier
doom ou ceux que j'ai été jetée de
capitaine d'un bateau mais je ne
l'entendais plus les riches vous voyez
j'ai été lui-même je voyais les vagues
joyet comme tout et je le voyais je me
faisais vraiment attaqué par des pirates
depuis que george était sorti d'un
prologue j'ai eu une étoile performance
mais moins chez l'homme même poche en
moins c'est ok c'était drôle parce que
j'entendais même plus les ruraux coin
petit short et comme une joke mais dans
ma tête c'est un bon job
mon personnage c'est ce qui vit excessif
ou des choses est positif pour un
humoriste parce que ce soit à l'île
maurice
moi je trouve que c'est une mauvaise
passe à leur peur du ridicule
il faut que ça point que les affaires
ridicule puis un comédien souvent
ça va accepter lui même la blague je
pense qu'il faut aller chercher un peu
de son humour ça devient tout devient
plus efficace qu'un humoriste bons
moments que tu acceptes que à défaut ça
peut être toi le salon de l'auto
dérision passe après toi là jo je pense
et c'est payant en jeu puis commença
même source un stand up pour commencer à
comme plus incarner les situations que
tu vas parler tous ces couples l'impro
ça peut être un bon exercice pour ce oui
oui pour apprendre après c'est justement
ce satané take it cela dans le restant
de ma vie parce que d'être profondément
l'amant présent posture analyser les
affaires ccc loctite ouallam sélective
mieux aussi
puis moi justement s'y met on était des
fois des situations sociales ou est-ce
que c'est du monde nouveau auquel tu
connais moins prêter comme en mode genre
chez paulo tijditt sous pillay trop tard
et je peux pas dire si ces gens des jeux
prédire ce puits latéraux titre aux
phrases plus loin puis le métro top 3 6
on a fait un malaise mais la décision de
le dire j'ai pensé à quelque chose mais
ce semaine comme moi car je tombe dans
ma tête dans cette zone le s6 que j'aime
pas ça mais ce n'est pas de casser m'est
arrivé une couple de fois déjà demande
que que j'estimais vraiment jeté comme
tellement j'ai vu tellement faire la
bonne affaire que tu fais rien la
séduction le oui mais c'est exact mais
celle plus qu'est ce qui t'intéresse
brillamment let's party comme un cheveux
de tout pour être naïve et la jda
excuse-moi médiatique marchait pas ça
l'avait vu comme ça que j'ai été que la
fiche m'accorde il serait amoureux
d'amour oui mais oui
c'est 100% moi des fois ça m'arrive
comme de tomber dans une jarre genre de
mode ou est ce que je suis dans une
école où est-ce que genre l'âge et du
fleuve fait d'école puisque oui je suis
vraiment ça que je suis comme des
enfants ces soirées le cij à hiesse
comme un soir j'étais bon et puis il ya
d'autres soirées c'est le journal
complètement ma blonde hamdi genre dans
sa famille comme sa famille ont remarqué
ok je regardais fois ph et comme
vraiment loupé c'est le gars le plus
drôle dans place puis à défaut est
exactement la même
à défaut je me gausse de chocs atteints
en danois belgique a pas de manque
d'habitude je suis comme je suis gosse
attitude et des sujets de conversation
étaient autrefois ces déchets posent des
questions tellement un match devenu
place je sais pas qu'est-ce qui fait ça
mais je ne sais pas pourquoi des
méchants persuadé c'est l'anxiété le
stress parce que c'est tout à ce moment
alors je me dis le j'essaye d'être comme
que je suis d'habitude et je suis pas
capable de l'atteindre parce que je
pense à être comme d'habitude puis moi
même je m'amuse - parce que je veux que
les gens s'amusent mais je pense à eux
rappelé à ce que ce soit moi que je
choisisse la faune ainsi s'attaquer aux
chinois mais
je veux dire je compte en combat là
dessus les gamins parce que ça m'arrive
pichot ces chiens on se l'est dit les
autres autrefois tient qu'en mettant sur
munster mène aussi quand tu arrives dans
l'événement parce que telle autre jour
on se l'est dit avec notre note réunion
de secondaire un terrain d'environ 10 en
secondaire depuis notre réunion de
secondaire humblement orienter les rois
du parti bien évidemment il n'y aurait
pas eu aucune façon qu'on ait pas de fun
parce que on est arrivé au début la
soirée puis on sait qu'il inquiète
montgueux long pour chanter du vote les
trous dans le sol on était 25 et puis on
arrive le père n'avait encore cette
énergie comme les gones en place par
tout le monde
il ya eu tout ce qui pouvait arriver
pour que la soirée schyle ont eu la
veine se moque machine ils ont juste
laisser partir c'est le comble ça va
passer la larme
c'est comme ça fait bip bip remy les
pompiers sont arrivés
ça a tué le 22 bat monde sont partis
bienvenue dans la rue de l'inde en
chambre n'était pas grave de se voir
quasiment moins de deux pieds mais quand
il ya eu un but de bitchage est aussi
les cadeaux qu'ils impliquaient paul oui
mais il nous autres on est resté avec
mon vieux on ne les applique tout la
crise dessous parce qu'on est en la
veste cet esprit là en arrivant au
canada soit on est dans une semaine son
poids dans cet atelier mais c'est parce
que je me disais fois que je rentre chez
nous c'est un logis t'es cool dit pour
crouch protégé par la prochaine fois que
je serai ce jeu vous soigner mais ça me
tirait de la porte va l'acheter narcisse
et plus de 70 par rapport à mon cas je
dis je suis qu'au lycée dans le sens que
je me sentais bien si je m'amuse et
vraiment ça comme je rie est bon ok
j'avais différentes je n'ai vraiment pas
ce que moi je m'en rends compte ait fait
pas ça me fait ça mais moi je m'en rends
compte maintenant l'intérêt que j'ai
pour les gens que des fois je suis trop
anxieux je parle de questions dont
je me suis même plus des réponses pour
parce que j'ai pas intérêt à voir la
personne mais j'ai trop stressé de
justement ça se passe bien que
normalement quand justement je me sens
vraiment bien je suis vraiment curieux
ça me fait du bien d'entendre les
réponses puis j'ai vraiment envie
d'entendre la personne qui à ce moment
là aussi ça paraît moins dans quand je
suis vraiment bien je me mets à
complimenter si je suis vraiment dans le
ça me fait plaisir ça me fait du bien on
se rend compte de ses débuts on vit
comme le cas à ça me fait quoi je suis
pas capable de dire de à la personne des
compliments parce qu'on dirait je
m'enlève quelque chose je la met sur un
piédestal par rapport à moins 1400 juste
bien que toi m'a fait faire un
compliment qu'on se croise à québec wen
très bon mode sais je sais que je t'aime
mais beaucoup phoenix pour phoenix suns
ont ajouté jeudi où phoenix à québec
pour le petit club succède au taquet
ouais c'est ça mais le site rythme avait
dit jeudi m'avait dit est extrêmement
limitée désolé mon iphone ipad castet je
me suis dit après jean rex des gones ce
genre de personne que je serais capable
de ça colle tout à fait mais ont-ils
quand il veut même pas que des amis mais
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qu'il ya quelque chose qui
m'est venue entendre quand tu parlais de
15 mai à penser à la prochaine question
parce que tu veux avoir la personne
intéressée c'est le début de la fin de
la conversation il n'y a rien qui se
passe après si ça arrive souvent que des
personnes plus âgées jardé mettons pas
des adultes mais des migrants parents et
des grands-parents ou est ce qu'on ne
peut rien qui nous connecte mais on n'a
pas de référent comment on n'a pas messi
je parle comme je parle aux gens de mon
ordre aux gens de ma génération ils vont
pas comprendre qu'est ce que je veux
dire c'est que le faut comme tu as juste
avec avec tous l'impression il faut que
tu parle de sujets rivière
comme faut que tu parles à l'ombre jetée
avait porté mon cher chez le garagiste
c'est tout le temps fourré à ottawa y
est c'est tout le temps fourré plus mon
pick up et aller le porter au fair play
ça tourne autour de quelque chose qui au
final tu te connaissent un peu c'est
quoi cet ogre en passe encore des soucis
d'enfants ben c'est ça qu'ils se soient
qui se disent on ne sait pas ce qu'il ya
en deux par exemple qu'ils y ont besoin
d'être certain
des fois je sais pas parce que j'ai
quand même quelqu'un d'assez peu importe
c'est positif ou négatif
je le vois des fois dans mes dans mes
relations sur tout ce travail arrêtée en
grosse blinde gel sa relation publique
je réalise des fautes souvent trop pour
cette personne-là de aussi qu'on est
rendus d'eux dans notre dans notre
relation que des fois je fais à le tout
et c'est je sais pas on dirait que des
fois les jeunes gens ont besoin de cette
fois et on voit ce détroit fera aux
virades
ça va être parfait ça va être tout un
point fait qu'on dirait peut-être qu'ils
s'amusent pas plus que toi mais en même
temps ça fait en sorte que parce que je
crois qu'il y en a qui connaissent
vraiment des liens puis même que c'est
positif au niveau carrière
j'avoue que j'ai ou lyon tall d'aller
chercher un roi était le projet comme
passant à moins de les 5 à 7 h et non
plus l'été n'aura pas de casque a été
bon quand didier qui longe âge mais il
ya vraiment une et steed ference en
s'asseoir jaser dans un podcast pige à
creuser quelqu'un oui mais oui temps
d'un 5 à 7 puis faire la conversation
mais le jeu capable de mettre catch un
peu plus le mot je me comprends mieux
moi même que je sais la dent dans ce
type de rencontre le il faut jouer au
jeu il ya ni requis
qu'il n'y ait un peu faux projets
sélectifs qu'on pose une question de pi
ca des projets déjà s'est vu que moi je
m'amuserais pas il faut j'emmène sur
ndjobi envoyé comme une pièce de base
ouvrier le fun que j'ai raison en est
que ce qu'est ce qui me rend mal à
l'aise cette fois s'est imposé sur sa
wii il faut que je développe un peu mais
ça me tente pas jailli sur la deux pays
pas mal de projets ou télécoms allez
salut ça va c'est juste la sa lu ça vole
au dessus puis le hockey jusqu'où est ce
que je suis prêt à répondre à cette
question le est-ce que je vais commencer
à faire ça va ça va moyen le sait
aujourd'hui c'était plutôt fait avec ma
blonde puis je sais pas trop qu'est ce
qu'on va faire
saint-gobain tu fais ouais mais moi des
fois c'est le mot qu est ce qui me fait
mal des fossés de renvoyer la question
là j'ai quand même et au savon c'est pas
quelqu'un sait on prend une petite
discussion mais justement c'est vraiment
vraiment dans le sens léger pour monia
is mélo le savons enfin huawei savons
parce que justement je le fais pas tout
ça va toi
il a même fait mal toi j'ai tué
merci j paul goulet fait ça vaut bien
c'est sur le travail pas mal fatigué je
m'entends dernière 20 juin des ménages
et la blonde dans une rue qui on donne
on doit avoir 30 en dessous de la
moyenne d'âge de la russie ok fake c'est
tout des voisins kiss kiss qu'à nice
dimanche
on est comme le nouveau jeune copain
dans la rue puis j'ai jamais autant de
conversation de surface que ceux de chez
nous à mon choix
comme à chaque jour une nouvelle
personne qui s'occupait des petits la
catr chez monsieur x je vais l'appeler
monsieur mon proprio si c'était la cata
chez monsieur x ouais ok des jeunes
ouais ouais ouais mais presque à 30a
c'est à moto ce qu'est c'est comme ça
tous les jours
c'est ce qu'il dit déménager dans un
foyer américain qui vient me torcher
main mais kaka c'est ça pour ça on aille
james a quand même une chaussure
réconfortante parce que j'avais un pied
à terre à grains brive que mon fils il y
avait avec sa mère à granby et mes
voisins j'ai trouvé mais y était pas non
c'est pas vrai y était pas sauf
ajustements c'était comme on le savait
que la relation était on se court au
long nez des voisins bon matin mais tu
le vois qu'ils ont comme pleut ça à
offrir justement puisque c'est un
tellement s'attend à un vrai beau bon
matin aïe ça vaut ça fait du bien car ça
aurait vraiment parce que
c'est un vrai ça va c'est pas juste
parce qu'on respecte les conventions
sociales
ça me fait plaisir et puis comme tout le
monde je veux pas tout à partir sur
parler du cosmos ces cartes mais aussi
des saveurs c'est donc un combat en
place notre place dans l'univers
c'est sûr de bien aller mais c'est vrai
qu'en vrai ça votre le sentier un vrai
favori c'est le droit des yeux puis
ticket genre ça m'intéresse comment tu
voles aux îles le justement la cassette
g8 nous apprend le bât blesse c'est
comme si la pauvresse à ce moment là on
parlait de même ce cas là mais ça
c'était c'était seulement début 2 les
avenues de sava pilotes
ouais ouais toi tu la fais à faire ça
vous ça va il me restait ma première
séance est qu elles seules de ça va oui
comme un silence des vraiment 30
secondes que la mouche bail il obtient
je prends deux gorgées d'eau vie il
simplement mener j
mais pourquoi de suivi et nick parce que
s'aventurer geslin vérifiant mamèche
christophe fax à vos acquis et s'étoffe
mais c'est là je suis en même temps un
bonnet forte à tabriz et mais pourquoi
tu pleures la semoy peuple domaine j'ai
fait je sais plus vielles en tout cas
merci de les battre c'est tellement puis
serge les ça vaut bien placé sur le
bouton c'est fou avec avec une bonne
intention mais on est tellement peur de
se faire demander sincèrement le savons
que ce chaque fois je me faisais le
supplice de la goutte d'or l'achat comme
à bonne place est ce qu on est tellement
habitué que ça soit pas bonne place a
fait ça va oui mais là on a un regret
d'avril savoure mais avec quelques tares
garde d'un tueur à gages by now by now
ça vaut quand tu peux pas y penser on le
titille que même si the way saison non
mais ça vous savez ça mais surtout que i
elle aurait pu elle avait pu rester
quatre minutes c'est vrai la stratégie
good will hunting
mais quand même c'est pas ta faute
d'adressé non tu le sais pas c'est un
circuit où des psychologues passent de
sperme humain sur les caravanes c'est
sûr mais c'est sûrement bien fait parce
que parce que j'ai l'impression que
robin williams il n'y a pas dû faire ce
n'est pas dû prendre ce rôle le léger et
y est pas dû dire je vois imiter un
missile il ya du fer non exposé format
mais c'est quand même c'est quand même
la technique rend le trait de ces tout
parce que moi j'ai eu une directrice qui
est un peu comme ça bien en échappée des
élèves ce genre ait outre rien de bon à
part travailler dans une usine
c'était pour les motiver à plus
technique le temps ayant acheté mais
comme un marché décolle parfait c'est
fait c'est miser gros la sorte que la
caisse
je serais curieux m'arrêter je pense que
autant de façons 3d puisque les gens
créent des psychologues de patients chez
moi c'est ça en plus il ya plusieurs
approches billets qu il le pense un plus
c'est avec talent et le puis tu parlais
pas tel état soir le pij entités n'ont
pas fermé c'était juste comme
j'attendais à prochaine question c'est
encore là il y en a qui vont tout petit
c'est moi j'ai eu
j'en ai d'autres j'ai trois psychologues
dit vraiment c'était les trois approche
complètement différente
la première était beaucoup dans attendre
que ce soit moins qui sortent quelque
chose
la deuxième c'est un petit peu plus
vraiment ciblé sur des trucs que je
voulais travailler c'était vraiment est
arrivé et mouiller sa censure pigot
exacte de la troisième était beaucoup
sur les chais morts beaucoup sur
vraiment c'était vraiment 10 et 10 trucs
quelque chose de vraiment on parlait pas
tellement c'était vraiment dit
et donc s'il ya vraiment beaucoup de da
proche parce que j'en ai connu troll
c'est vraiment différent
qu'est-ce qui a fait que tu es ce que tu
di nallo tu la première en fait c'était
juste à cause de la distance
parce que moi j'ai passé comme une
annick j'étais vraiment tout temps tout
en plein été avec mon fils justement
grand baie donc elle s'était c'était un
grand bruit
ensuite d'autres ça en revenant à
montréal de façon permanente d'alger
comme switcher pour avoir une
psychologue à montréal et celle là
pourquoi c'est à cause qu'elle avait une
cliente qu'on se connaît et sait ne peut
pas avoir comme la brume ce colloque que
quelqu'un qui n'a que je connais qui
expire ce pays qui bouge et que moi
c'est ça ça fait genre cinq semaines
hockey qui est je sais pas exactement ce
qu'on s'en approche mais moi la rive qui
je parle
ok puis je te longue j'arrive qui a dit
ça vaut puis ce fut pauvre et noir
pendant cinq ans mais aucune à la fin a
dit bon mais on va s'arrêter
mais le site est le théâtre cinquième ou
si c'est un gars de ton espace utilise
comme tous mes problèmes en cas va
t'arriver un m'amener à gears avec ela
madi prochain avec une liste prochain
cours prochainement
des prochaines rencontres on va faire un
bilan
bulletin fait capoter cela il y avait
une nouvelle que j'avais entendu je
pense qu'il ya un an d'un psychologue
excité suisse dry pittis fait imagine
ses clients qui font encore mais la
personne qui m'a aidé à quel point mes
problèmes sont l'eau s'est passé parce
que non mais je sais qu'ils en même
temps mais ton mettons une vie où est ce
que m quelqu'un qui s'en va en
psychologie kaki super besse sancy et
empathique pendant qu'en toi ça va moins
bien au niveau professionnel
au niveau personnel tu veux dans ta job
tout ce que tu entends c'est du monde
qui vont pire que toi ou qui vont mal
ça doit quand j'avoue que c'est le 2éme
en même temps le sentiment aussi d'aider
ces personnes doit amener qui met son
nez dans voici donc pas le sentiment
d'être vraiment ouais c'est comme toi le
chp a cité le ton le tarif là tu parles
part à 50 minutes le west qu'elle
al'impression de t&d vraiment je sais
pas filtré vu que tu parles toute la
longue un filtre comment mener des lots
d'oublier ton porte-monnaie pourra
revenir et puis voir ses effets sur pied
déjà fait tout danger ou banques
surviennent deux concorde était brûlée
débarbouillette d'eau froide sur le
front moi j'ai fait ça pour gaming pour
voter comme je me trouvais l'océan ce
lot puis le gg j'ai oublié comme mon
porte monnaie mais comme j'ai fait
exprès c'est involontaire survenu juste
pour vous si j'allais la surprend le
chamamé yannick axe vite imposé quoi me
faut que je suis là dessus je suis en
train de me chercher j'ai écrit à des
jamais personne
prends des nouveaux clients un fait que
le faut je continue mes recherches
des fois c'est là on a des fois ça peut
prendre deux ou trois mois avant d'avoir
quelqu'un nom et qualité sur l'ordre des
psychologues
ces cas là mais j'ai comme l'est déjà en
grosse salle rayon autour de chez nous
il ya comme une clean et qui adore 200 m
de chez nous mais un système
d'assistanat aussi najjar dans un truc
de dentiste hockey et agents des bureaux
de placement mais on m'avait dit pour de
mérite de prendre tout le temps approche
parce qu'on faisait quand même c'est
comme aller au jam moi ce sera les
proches sinon se reconnaît par puis a
laissé un genre qui s'abritent pezens
ouais ouais c'est clairement défini six
matches et vous de ce projet des sujets
vous populeux éventuellement mais mais
j'ai quand même l'impression que même ce
même c'est juste parler peut-être
récemment les feedbacks mots je pensais
que j'allais avoir justement des trucs
ou jordi d'aidé qle ou des réponses le
0-0 réponse mais quand même le fait de
baliser des affaires s'affaisse a fait
la primature pense qu'il sera pas sa
semaine personnes d'après trio un
processus que personne dans vicky
estoril pour vrai resto poste pas ça
dans ma vie quelqu'un quitte ekotto
autant mais c'était qui
à ces tests et guillaume guillon dans le
podcast avec alix bisaillon qui est ce
qu on dirait qu'ils n'auront que l'une
disait qu'avec sa copine justement ils
se font des tice en sciences exactes et
une heure de c'est toi qui parles
puis après ça c'est toi qui parles tu
n'as pas le droit de contester ait pas
d'accord non non c'est écoute c est
wassim ben arfa
je sais écouter sans rien dire jusqu'en
mai en même temps c'est tellement vrai
chez répond en même temps c'est avoir la
meilleure chose en lui mais rask était
bien dans ces situations-là
d'engueulades justice se met toujours
duel sur le feu quand répondre
honnêtement souvent c'est vrai dans
l'émotion ouais ou qu'elle se tient à
l'écart des réponses mais le cas s'est
cassé c'est le but et je vais tout à ses
cages margalef mes copines le résultat
je dirai rien je veux pas été moitié
ferme et autant pour savez les rendent
compte en verser heureuse d'entendre
quelques messages à aller au lit mieux
de la personne non mais dans n'importe
quoi je veux comme j'aime ce genre est
capable de comprendre ce biais la
personne pour des raisons que je veux
que des fois ça c'est parce que mais ça
me faisait défaut désagréable j'aime ça
avec mes amis pareils mais surtout de la
perrière non non ouais mais notre l'abc
j'ai l'impression que si en réalité tu
peux parler à tes amis outils à tourner
autour de toi sauf qui est elle à dire
pas quelque chose qui va se faire aller
plus mal qu'il n'ya pas non plus de quoi
t'as pas une relation amicale officer de
quoi puis la personne qu'on vend à
pognon ou cicta pas de recul cédant
l'émotion fait que regretter que la
personne change de perception par
rapport à tous et de saluer ta relation
amicale
tu disais tantôt psychologue jeudi c'est
pour ça que 3 h repas perception tour je
ne sais pas si je peux y ce box avis
c'est une vraie s'arrête en quart et à
la prochaine volvo est encore dans son
bureau entre angels
c'est vrai mais ce caméléon au
confessionnal mais de jeu c'est à lille
livret livret à paroles sans risquer de
briser rien sur un lieu pour aller vivre
étant des redevances et au confessionnal
des rues devant wayne
qu'est-ce qu'il va y va tout en
confessionnal c'est jean ferry pâle qui
la praille qui répond pas par les
disques en dieu te pardonne qui j ai
bien avec ce kit a eu des mots sa seule
place qui y en parle qui fait baisser
vous savez prend le match lui qui plus
est
j'avais juste une messe pour le biais
médicale mais dieu de parts dans sa
réponse que les fans de comics une des
passions qui tentons super héros
préférés en ce moment ça change ça
change souvent
le gie country pécresse en bray
l'académie g j'écoutais comme le service
netflix d'après ce que j'ai lu les comic
books
sinon en ce moment green arrow j'aimais
bail classique batman et études genre
assuré mettant toutes les îles mettons
toutes les univers parallèles dans
lesquelles les histoires peuvent se
passer quand même parce que mon fils qui
est vraiment vraiment ans au fait qu'on
relit comme les inscriptions aéro
ensemble j'aimerais le surfeur d'argent
ouais ouais son chemin dans l'esprit non
j'aime ça général mais je sais pas ce
serait moi je sais par green arrow
c'était mon préféré un bourrelet je sais
pas je n'y avait qu'une liste les gestes
à cause de grâce à robert downey junior
vraiment car ils ont bien fait je le il
y avait une liste les harley c'était
comme les les x men et les x-men sont
comme classés sur les catégories de
pouvoir plus deux comme la catégorie
ultime qui étaient commis à jardy s'ils
sont répertoriés je disais comme n'y a
que quelques fois dans le classement des
plus forts mais avec une courte
description de la mythologie des x-men
pigeard les deux les deux plus forts
lincicome
il ya une mention deux autres dans un d
une des baies d'épisodes qui font pas
vraiment d'apparition mais c'est juste
qu'ils me font partie de la mythologie
du truc moi ça va loin en salle
cd howe c'est énorme comme l'univers
s'il faut en plus et le team et on brûle
academy c'est même en dehors de ces 90
enfants et moi attendent et on a quand
même beaucoup
oui et d'ailleurs il ya une série par
exemple qui est vraiment bonne que
quiconque n'est pas fan de super héros
c'est vraiment bien fait c'est pas
classique c'est l'hygiène ça dit quoi
ouais merci c'est dans l'univers des
x-men d'enfants ouais ben c'est le fils
de professeur xavier qui est comme
considérer justement un des plus
puissants mais la série est vraiment
bien fait parce que il est comme lui
dans un gymnase il faut que ça se passe
beaucoup dans sa taille ses tripes ce
qui est des jeux est ce que nous mettons
les limites les mutants sont acceptés
dans société
c'est dans ce jeu comme une carrière
classique le comme une carpe à ce que
sont les mutants sont trop puissants qui
font par son s'il y en a un qui dit le
monde qui en a tout le temps et qui va
anéantir le monde sinon ce serait pas
une série noire mais c'est vraiment un
bon pour dresser rabelais c'est
intéressant parce que c'est des mutins
mais ce n'est pas tout des mutants mais
mettons les personnages principaux c'est
d'imiter avec des poux au psy chic que
cette peine à intéresser puis 18 ans que
je vends pas de punch mais il ya comme
un air mutin l'intérieur de sa taille tu
pas que ça se passe beaucoup beaucoup à
l'intérieur de sa tête et il ya des
éléments aussi qui se passe à
l'extérieur à cancon rendent à
l'intérieur c'est comme hip hop ce qui
est des lits que ça devient assez haïti
c'est moi c'est vraiment un bon ben
c'est vraiment pas dans le classique
2 qu'est ce qu'on voit d'habitude de six
autres films de super héros
ce roman graphique est juste
c est parce que c'est vraiment méthodes
et ça joue vraiment que les codes du
genre pisam henry un peu salée
déconstruit salue pimousse avais je
connaissais pas le roman graphique avant
de voir le film
puis il fait bon mais le film you will
type de film et comme tu sais pas quel
genre que c'est justement plus modulable
ce qui arrive quand même temps c'est pas
sérieux puisse par violeurs des fois
mais ces sols comme xbox
il y en a beaucoup qui connaissent pas
cette dépense pour enfermer caroline
même des débattements qu'à partir des
premières séries adaptées pour les
enfermer quand l'hymne des mondiaux
j filtrer les bd parce que moi je
connais un peu surpris mais ton de
killing joke des agressions sexuelles la
dass et violet enfin annoncer ça à la
base
en plus de suivre la propagande
politique ça à la base il ya beaucoup
d'étudiants dans les comic books par
exemple bain juste chez geo livre qui
parle dans le fond de chaque super héros
est souvent en lien avec un courant de
pensée ou du moins c'est ça mais je
devrais pas dire n'importe quoi j'ai pas
d'exemples concrets qui me vient en tête
a été un peu juste captain america est à
la barre
oui mais oui c'est ultra patrie c'est
que quand je me souviens qu'en que
méchants russes qui de temps à c'est ça
quand il ya des superman était sorti
surfeurs
tu es 5 6 ans et dessus mais nasty
premier le premier des nouveaux le genre
je me suis je prenais des cours de philo
or faculté l'autre monétisant musique
mais j'ai pris des cours de philo pis on
en avait parlé dans un chaos parce
qu'apparemment dans ce film-là qui
vraiment ses premiers degrés sur l
affaire il ya foule de références à
platon qu'ils puissent eux mêmes même tu
vois que la tienne 6 lits genre la
république de platon j'empile déposé
libye puis il ya vraiment tout un second
dégré dit les éclaircies qui est sous
jacent
j'avais prévu demain mais j'avoue que
dans l idole c'est comme blanc avant de
présenter les les livres de philo qui
analysent comme quelque chose qui est
très pop culture
le designer pour recel de vol de legend
of zelda wii
j'allais je l'aimé je dépôt lui mais moi
j'avais je ne sais pas quel point par
exemple c'est de l'interprétation ou
cédera réfléchi malte en sauce et l'art
en général
c'est ce regard d'une dup médicaments -
c'est comme la douleur d'un passé que
finalement non l'artiste est tombé puis
échappé de la période
c'est pas ça qui est potes démarche
alors est ce que met d'ailleurs même
film j'ai appuyé là c'est le nouveau
joker moi avec
avec joaquin phoenix ça ça va être c'est
que là il ya une folie déjà la base qui
va amener 0 1
j'espère un acteur je pensais qu'ils
allaient jouer un personnage de bd donc
je sais ce club qui s'est claqué une
danse a vraiment l'air d'être amené très
différemment
connaissez vous ce qu'ils ont réussi à
faire avec le joker c'est quand ledger
fait le job que tout le monde a dit le
joker c'est fini une personne qui va
faire le joker plans précédents succès
du quad c'est jared leto qui fenêtre
patron du jour que qui a rien à voir
avec ce que les jo a fait qui est quand
même cool sommes toutes deux enfants un
autre qui a l'air complètement europe
quand même cool aussi ses gaffes
d'allemagne jobin nom puis andré tout le
monde et tout à perdre c'est comme même
en fac batman après celle au real je
trouvais plus que correct je le trouve
froid qui est bon mais c'est juste les
firmes soucy squad il vraiment pas de
toi mais justement vos dessins de ben
affleck je te comme pour le leur et
celle ci n'était bonne piste et un il
faisait partie des six autres clubs où
j'ai trouvé vraiment intégré ce jeu là
j'ai trouvé bon mauvais la clé parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui s'opposent
au changement général sur tout cas c'est
des trucs sont tellement proche de leurs
attentes et les super héros ça ça fait
partie le la psyché des gentilés fan fan
fan c'est vraiment formateur pour eux
fait que le changement de métier il y
aussi des fois amené y ont fait une
overdose de 8 buts
si on était des fois je sais que ton
opinion là dessus et métiers à paris
j'en aurai jamais trop en examen oui je
sais je consomme de tout mais c'est vrai
mon plaisir coupable pour donner surtout
si c'est mon mon fils le liant aux api
salle fétiche mais aussi que ce soit que
sa salle amplifie mon intégration parce
que williams ofakim on en parle qu'on
échange l'accusé même qu'on va voir
ensemble tactique en france 4 500 une
traîne avec un avec un acteur
réalisateur et ont comme je t'aime à
l'ailé
les gars de christine hollande pilote de
huit buts et un nouveau batman
tant que les importations change ses
méthodes changent mais moi aussi parce
que comme le dit un plaisir coupable
j'ai pas je rentre pas dans le même
monde analytique que quand j'écoute
d'autres termes ces jeunes gens un
bonbon pour moi c'est juste que ces pays
du sud qui fait que maintenant le joker
joaquin phoenix en tant que c'est pas un
serment reebok lance une autre
interprétation qu elle sait c'est la
genèse du personnage c'est autre chose
parlant de ont parlé d' analyses de
certains films sous un angle précis
juste avant quand je vais rester j'avais
fait un cours sapaient avril jose puis
parents disent mais non on lisait la
bible dans le fond puis on a parlé en
groupe pour en analyser comme cette
comprendre d'un point de vue pendant
point de vue théologique mais d'abord
une vue genre de c'est quoi ces courts
messages de soutien puis en même temps
faisait un cours de cinéma
ph qui ont déjà fait mon travail final
sur une analyse qui retiennent une
analyse très de béton religieuse de
robocop points et puis il ya tellement
de référence à jésus puis à la bible
robocop c'est vraiment voulu c'est le
réalisateur les auteurs s'étaient ils
ont placé le vraiment et si même les
scènes qui est un tissu pouvoir ils
marchent sur l'eau péter outre
l'impression qu'ils marchent sur l'eau
au puits genre c'est la dernière scène
est tellement parallèle travaillé en
classe affaires
mais ce intéressante et des films que tu
doute pas mais matière vraiment à
pousser l'analyse pareil mais surtout
l'histoire de jésus nous on dirait que
souvent tu peux faire le lien beaucoup
de choses
- notamment secours la lisant la bible
je me rends compte à quel point les
références religieuses sont
omniprésentes
autant alors que la société en général
bon je fais des choses à faire rejeter
ces de locservice soit cette histoire là
qu'on a tous entendu soit c'est juste
soit cette valeur le qui comme une
maison au québec ça nous vient de ses
réseaux ses malades robocop n'est pas
laïque avec la police
partout dans les écoles puis y ait des
signes religieux ostentatoires il trop
d'alcool
alors merci beaucoup d'avoir été là
c'était super cool d'avoir faire sécher
le promets bakou ci-dessus plug était
enfant oui quantité en show bientôt tu
parles
ouais ben justement ce soir à repentigny
mais j'espère que ça va sortir un peu
importe leur exacte l'armée fait le
monde sait maintenant que c'est une
blague mais avec un accent aigu sur le
pourquoi tomber sur un site
d'information sur souriant jean taris
que celui que